abilities but as you say the backdrop to
all of this is the new record that we
had yesterday
430 migrants making that crossing the
last time that this record was hit or
anything like it was back in september
where we had 416
people making that journey of course
yesterday we saw just along the
coastline over here in dover a bit
further down on one of the beaches we
had men women and children
coming ashore disembarking from the
vessel they were on many of them
exhausted relieved but some of them
celebratory too of course they have paid
an
awful lot of money for that crossing the
people smugglers
making the most out of this business and
it is very much a business for them
could see them charging some 3 000 maybe
up to 5 000
pounds for a ticket on that boat and of
course there's no guarantee that you're
going to reach the other side
below us today we know the border force
vessels have been out this morning
they've yet to return
we are waiting to see whether more
migrants or suspected migrants are going
to make it ashore today
meanwhile of course the debate on that
bill will take place later in parliament
things on the cards
reforms to the way in which migrants are
dealt with when they come into the uk
but also a difference in how the uk
resettlement scheme
will work we could see an indefinite
leaf to remain being given to
people we are currently seeing live
pictures of
a boat crossing the channel a small rib
uh
coming in uh but it we should also put
this in context because although there
has been an increase in traffic
like this across the channel i think the
overall statistics show that
migrants and asylum seekers coming to
britain are actually slightly down
they're slightly down when it comes to
other means of crossing but when it
comes to
migration on water that is still such a
contentious issue
last year when we saw the home secretary
claiming saying that this route was
unviable
she wanted people to stop taking this
dangerous route and it's incredibly
dangerous when the weather
isn't like it is today but still we're
talking about the busiest shipping lane
in europe perhaps even in the world
and even though the weather is as it is
it is such a risk
and increasingly we're seeing not only
men making this journey but
women and children too and they're
paying a lot of money
for a chance at a new life they're
looking over
seeing other people having reached the
other side many of them looking very
happy to have reached the other side
and they're seeing them being taken care
of and word does get back
of course we have seen the uk paying
france
a lot of money to up the surveillance
but we are talking about
miles and miles of coastline on the
other side of northern france but also
parts of belgium
that need patrolling and once the police
crack down on one of the beaches you
find they pop up elsewhere and again
the routine starts once more so it's a
bit of a cat-and-mouth situation
for certainly the authorities in france
but also here too